OK, let's unpack this.
Today we're embarking on a deep
dive into an idea that's, well,
it's fascinating and for many
may be quite uncomfortable how
we divide ourselves.
And we're not talking about the
usual lines like race or class
here.
Instead, we're going to explore
a concept the source material
we're looking at boldly calls
cultural apartheid.
And it has some surprising,
maybe even shilling implications
for society today.
Our mission really is to
understand this unique form of
division, how it shows up, how
it manifests, and what it
suggests about the bigger
picture.
And we're doing this through the
lens of Chris Abraham's piece
Opt in Apartheid, Cultural
Apartheid in the Age of
Inclusion.
Yeah.
And what's truly fascinating, I
think, is how Abraham's piece
just challenges our basic
assumptions about division.
He suggests that this isn't, you
know, traditional oppression
from the top down.
It's something different,
something chosen, maybe
community and forest.
I didn't quite subtle.
The core definition he gives is
really clear.
Cultural apartheid is when
identity is police not by
melanin, but by perceived
assimilation or deviation from
the dominant cultural group,
whether that group is minority
or majority.
So the shift is from the outside
markers to internal ones.
Behavior.
Exactly.
It's about behavior, about how
you act, not just how you look.
And Abraham gives some pretty
striking examples right away,
doesn't he?
To make it concrete, he talks
about his experience growing up
in Hawaii.
He says the line wasn't drawn by
color as much as by behavior.
Nobody cared if you were white,
brown, Asian or black if you
knew how to act right.
Right, but if you didn't.
Yeah, if you acted white, which
he defines as being uptight,
arrogant, overly formal, you got
well roasted for it.
And he mentions terms like
Twinkies for Asian and Pacific
Islander kids speaking mainland
English or getting into elite
schools, and Oreos for black
kids seen as acting similarly.
The essay really hammers this
home.
It wasn't about skin.
It was about code.
It's a powerful reframing, isn't
it?
Saying your actions, your code,
that's your real ID within that
group.
And this isn't just like a local
thing or something from the
past.
He brings it right into the
press with a really prominent
example.
Supreme Court Justice Clarence
Thomas.
The piece points it's out how
Thomas is often called the black
face of white supremacy, and it
argues this isn't about his DNA,
obviously, but because of his
politics, his diction and his
refusal to perform the expected
cultural role.
And the key observation, the
punishment isn't for being
black, it's for being off code.
And those examples really nailed
down this idea of opt in
apartheid, these community
enforced boundaries that demand
loyalty to a cultural group or
else it's a very different
dynamic than we usually discuss
when we talk about oppression.
You know, it kind of reminds me
of that movie Idiocracy.
Remember when the main
character, the time traveler,
speaks normally articulately and
everyone mocks him for sounding
quote gay?
Yeah, I remember that.
The joke isn't really about his
sexuality, right?
It's that he sounds too
polished, too different from the
norm in that future society.
That's cultural deviance.
That's being off code.
Exactly.
And if we pull back and look at
the bigger picture here, what
Abraham seems to be highlighting
is this shift, a shift away from
purely external forces of
oppression.
Towards something more internal.
Yeah, towards internal
enforcement within the group
itself.
It changes how division can
function.
And Abraham makes it clear this
isn't just about race or class.
He says it also includes things
like language, dress, effect and
even aspiration.
It's much broader.
And what's really insightful are
some of the maybe surprising
examples he uses.
He looks beyond the common
stereotypes towards affluent
black communities, places like
Atlanta, Oakland, Brentwood, the
DC suburbs, the tri-state area.
Places you might think those old
divisions would start to break
down.
You might think so, but he
argues these aren't just
economic ghettos.
These are, in his words, bougie,
educated, well resourced
communities.
And yet, according to the piece,
they function as cultural
ecosystems, ones that actually
reinforce cultural separation
rather than dissolving it.
Wow, so affluence doesn't
necessarily mean integration,
culturally speaking.
Not always, according to this
view.
And this leads him to discuss
groups like the Boule.
He describes them as black
elites who operate in high
society, often using like,
transatlantic English,
navigating elite spaces very
fluently.
OK, but the crucial point he
makes is that they're often seen
as less black by cultural
nationalists, and it's not
because of their wealth or their
politics necessarily.
Just because they don't stick to
the expected code.
Exactly because they code switch
effectively.
Or maybe they never coded in
that expected way to begin with.
This also sort of connects that
whole Ebonics debate back in the
90s which the author mentions.
Right.
He calls it a controversial,
revealing attempt to codify
cultural speech and resist
linguistic assimilation.
So it wasn't just about
language, but identity.
Yeah, it highlighted how deep
these cultural markers run.
It was about identity and
loyalty, about resisting the
pull of the so-called master's
tongue.
OK.
So we've kind of defined this
cultural policing, this code,
but what's the actual cost?
What's the impact?
Abraham seems to think it's
pretty significant.
Oh, absolutely.
He puts it very starkly.
He says when speech becomes a
badge, it becomes a prison.
It's a really powerful metaphor
for how this can limit people.
A prison that's that hits hard.
How does that prison work?
How does that cage manifest
itself?
Well, he explains it like this.
When ambition becomes acting
white, when etiquette becomes
betrayal, when eloquence is met
with side eye, The doors don't
close from the outside, we close
them ourselves.
So.
It's self-imposed.
That's the argument.
And he shares this really
personal story about his mother,
how she raised him to be fluent
in both worlds.
At home is very proper, you
know, Manhattan, English,
NPRPBS, etiquette, poetry,
atlases.
But outside, she let him run
wild with pigeon slippers.
Rap, rap, linger.
The local Hawaiian vernacular.
So she was teaching him code
switching basically as a tool.
Exactly.
He got fluent in the local way
of speaking, but she always
taught him to switch back.
She saw it as preparation, as a
necessary survival skill.
And yet, Abraham observes, in
today's world, it's treated like
treason.
That difference in perception is
key.
It really is, and it raises this
important question, how does
this internal policing compare
to, say, traditional external
racism?
The essay draws a sharp
contrast.
Abraham mentions going into
white supremacist online spaces,
and even there his precise
English isn't enough, Doesn't
matter how well he writes or
speaks.
Because to them it's about
blood, not code.
Precisely.
He's still undermen, subhuman
because his blood isn't pure, so
his code doesn't save him there,
which reinforces his main point.
This isn't just about race or
language or class in isolation.
It's about culture and who gets
to own it, define it, gate keep
it.
And let's be really clear here,
because Abraham emphasizes this
too.
There's nothing inherently wrong
with cultural pride.
That's vital.
But here's where he draws the
line.
When it becomes an opt in
apartheid, when it starts to
punish success, ambition,
assimilation, or even basic
competence, it stops being
pride.
It starts being a cage.
And then?
He takes it a step further.
He suggests this cultural
apartheid isn't even the whole
story.
He proposes it might be part of
something.
This is where it gets really
provocative, right?
He calls it only one part of a
broader design, a design he
labels a program of opt in
control, or even eugenics with a
smile.
Which is a deeply chilling
phrase.
It is.
The idea he puts forward is
essentially if the powers that
be, the man as he puts it, can
convince you, convince whole
groups to self select out of
success, reproduction and
mobility.
He doesn't need to suppress you,
you'll do it for him.
He calls it social engineering
in plain sight, and he lists
some specific strategies he sees
at play.
First, convincing communities
that striving for excellence is
a betrayal.
OK.
Second, framing ambition as
assimilation as selling out.
3rd, pushing narratives that
valorize grievance over growth,
focusing on past wrongs rather
than future progress.
And finally, celebrating
cultural insularity and shame.
Code switching making it seem
wrong to adapt or operate in
different cultural contexts.
And it doesn't stop there.
He talks about incentivizing
dependence, making it, quote,
easier to live on the dole than
to start a business, penalizing
families for staying together,
discouraging marriage, elevating
the value of abortion and
childlessness while mocking
those who build households, and
celebrating isolation, delay and
sterilization.
Literally and metaphorically,
it's a bleak picture of
manipulation.
It really is, and the shift he
outlines is profound.
To summarize his point, we've
gone from forced segregation to
self-imposed separation, from
externally mandated sterility to
culturally celebrated
barrenness, from being told we
can't succeed to probably
declaring we won't even try.
It's a sobering trajectory that
Abraham wants us to see.
So wrapping this up, what does
this all mean for us?
For you?
Listening this deep dive into
cultural apartheid, as Abraham
frames it, really reveals a
complex, often hidden dynamic.
It forces us, I think, to
grapple with his final, quite
stark assertion.
This isn't just cultural
apartheid.
It's opt in apartheid, wrapped
in identity, pride and served up
his justice.
Yeah.
And connecting this back to the
listener, it leaves us with a
really critical question to
think about something inspired
by the author's underlying call
to awareness perhaps.
How do we get better at
identifying these dynamics,
these pressures that might, you
know, subtly encourage us or
others to self select out of our
full potential, especially when
they're presented not as
limitation but as cultural pride
or loyalty?
A challenging question.
Definitely maybe something to
observe, you know, and the
messages we receive, the
expectations we feel in our own
environments.